welcome back to las vegas now this
weekend is not only valentine's day but
it's also presidents day weekend
and to celebrate john barr is offering
huge savings at finley toyota check this
out
a heart-shaped box filled with
chocolates makes a wonderful valentine's
day gift
but then again so does a brand new
toyota
hey john happy valentine's day wow jc
thank you i didn't know you felt that
way about
of course you're one of my favorites
here in las vegas oh now not only is it
valentine's day this weekend it's also
president's day weekend and you have
some huge specials going on
tell us what you have big specials
complimentary registration on all new
cars
and our blowouts as far as our 2020s
that still remain here
don't have many left want to get rid of
every one of them now the complementary
registration it's savings it's me on two
levels one you're saving a lot of money
and you're saving time so you have to go
to the dmv and deal with everything
correct
we have a service that helps with that
as well so it can be like a one
shop stop correct that works for me
sounds good did i say that right i think
so and then i've got the shop at the
stop the wrong way around
one stop yeah you get it all done here
at finley toyota we do and you have
every time i come down here i feel very
safe all kinds of covert protocols in
place
well thank you we do we have obviously
got our own equipment that we've
purchased
we have deep cleans every day and we
know the importance of keeping things
safe during these times really soon
you know john finley toyota is kind of
like it's like a box of chocolates you
never know what you're gonna get when
you come down that's for sure jc in fact
we have something
for everyone
[Music]
whoa oh god you like that i i do
i like that that's a beautiful
highlander well you deserve it we can
arrange that we can get you that new car
why not and
oh cool sure did you have specials on
this this weekend we have specials
specials not only just the company
registration we're going to give you
but on top of that you've got rebates or
interest rates is your choice
all right do the snap again
[Music]
whoa this snapping thing is cool and so
is this is a crawler this is a corolla
yes it is in fact 2021 corolla but of
the vehicles we got the special special
special dylan
we have 20 20s in the crows so so this
weekend the 2020 this is the 21 the 2020
crawlers you got to move them out of
here right we do
we do can i can i try the snap thing try
it
try it
a slide jc leave the snap into me please
[Music]
yeah oh this is what i'm talking about
john you like this one i
i love this one when did you guys bring
back the supra came back
last year 2020 and this is a 2021 model
in canary yellow canary yellow is the
color for jc now this weekend with the
complimentary registration does that
apply to this car
it does it does now john uh i brought
you your valentine's day gift you got
one for me
i think you know what you want and i
think i know what you want
i will see you later my friend see you
later happy president's day happy
valentine's day
i'm out of here all right we need the
snap effect in all of your
all of your future packages finley
toyota is located in henderson call them
at 702-566-2573